what do Snoop Dogg gwyneth paltrow an ex
Speaker of the House John Boehner all
have in common besides their Spotify
Discover weekly playlists they're all
major investors in a budding new
industry legalized cannabis production
once a taboo topic pot is going
mainstream a 2018 Pew Research poll
found that 62% of Americans believe
marijuana should be legalized the
highest number in the last 50 years with
the recent law changes in Canada and
some US states the legal winds seemed to
be shifting for cannabis and nothing
helps span the flames have changed like
the prospect of making some serious
green a 2018 research study projected
medical marijuana sales to grow by 36
percent per year making it a 55 billion
dollar industry by 2024 and CBD a
derivative of cannabis was projected to
grow by 700 percent between 2016 and
2020 the rapid explosion of the cannabis
industry is taking the investing world
by storm but can this high last forever
or will it soon burn out
[Music]
how did cannabis become illegal anyway
for thousands of years cannabis was
considered a common useful medicine to
aid with a large array of ailments and
pains but all that changed following the
1910 Mexican revolution which resulted
in a new wave of Mexicans immigrating to
the US to seek about her life the
suspicion and fear of these immigrants
extended to their tradition of smoking
cannabis American law enforcement
demonized the drug as an insider of
crime and violence and rebranded it
under its scary foreign sounding name
States quickly began regulating and
outlawing the use of marijuana and by
1970 the federal government passed a law
making it a Schedule one drug
meaning according to the DEA it's more
dangerous than cocaine or
methamphetamine and has zero medical
benefits our prisons are still crowded
with inmates disproportionately
minorities whose initial offenses were
related to cannabis for most of the 20th
century the majority of Americans
believed that marijuana should be
outlawed
but today popular and legal sentiment
has turned to favor cannabis once again
it might remind you of when a hundred
years ago another big swing happened to
a popular recreational drug alcohol in
1933 the twenty-first amendment repealed
prohibition the 13-year long period in
our nation's history when the production
or sale of alcohol was illegal this was
partly a reaction to popular sentiment
but it's also because the feds were
looking for an economic stimulant and
they saw the potential of harvesting the
taxes from legal alcohol sales their bet
paid off big-time
alcohol production exploded and within a
year of repeal the alcohol tax income
added 9% to the entire federal budget
see banning alcohol didn't stop people
from drinking they just found creative
workarounds and a black market was
created that benefited organized crime
by legalizing alcohol the government
could spend less time chasing
bootleggers and more time collecting tax
revenue these same arguments are being
made today for cannabis there are a few
key differences between legalized
marijuana and pro
Bishan cannabis production and
possession has been criminalized for
much longer than alcohol ever was
none of us lived in a time when the drug
was fully legal and while some states
allow legal production the federal
government still doesn't
this leaves cannabis in illegal haze the
federal government seems to defer to the
states rights and not enforce the
standing law for now as money floods
into this blooming market cannabis
companies are sprouting like weeds
together they've had an estimated
economic impact of 16 billion dollars in
2017 alone with total US revenue
approaching that of mega corporations
like Netflix and McDonald's and in 2017
the industry employed around a hundred
and fifty thousand full-time workers
which is roughly the same number of
librarians or kindergarten teachers in
the country and remember these figures
are from 2017 before California had even
legalized cannabis for recreational use
they're probably much much higher today
now before you buy into this cushy new
lifestyle some blunt truth it might be
an exciting new field but all of the
same rules of a stock market still apply
investing in single company stocks
inherently carries what experts call
unsystematic risk that means that even
though a sector may grow over all
individual companies might be half-baked
consider the dot-com boom of the early
2000s though the internet was clearly
here to stay
countless startups with dubious business
plans failed and there are investors
dollars when went up in smoke the same
can be said of any exciting new trends
like 3d printing or cryptocurrency
you can avoid unsystematic risk by
diversifying your stash
for example instead of selecting
individual stocks you might look into a
cannabis comprised mutual fund or ETF
which rolls up hundreds of different
holdings into one entity you can refer
to our episode on mutual funds for a
deeper dive but the basic premise is
that you get the benefit of investing in
a certain sector while spreading your
risk across multiple companies but
buying a fund isn't a surefire bet
either since the industry is new
cannabis companies are
Merilee small-cap which means their risk
of failure is especially high so it's
not surprising that these funds are
subject to wild swings trailblazing
industries tend to suffer from fits and
starts and this one is no different a
single court ruling or new law might
reshape the landscape overnight even a
potential green gold mine like legalized
cannabis is subject to the laws of
supply and demand take Oregon which
legalized cannabis sales in 2014 where a
flood of speculators eager to cash in
has led to a massive oversupply
according to the Associated Press there
are over a million pounds of dried
cannabis in the Oregon supply system
with no way to profitably dispose of it
this has led to a collapse of prices
with a drop of 50% in the price per
ounce since 2015 talk about a buzzkill
it looks like legal cannabis is here to
stay for the foreseeable future
before you place a big bet on these
companies it's critical you have a sound
grasp of equity investing fundamentals
like market size p/e ratios volatility
if you're unfamiliar with these concepts
you should start by seeking the guidance
of an investment advisor who's a legal
fiduciary together you can hash out a
plan to realize your financial goals as
with any speculative investment no
matter how exciting never gamble more
than you're willing to lose if things go
to pot and that's our two cents have you
invested in cannabis production or any
other emerging industry tell us about it
in the comments
you